[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the new hogwarts legacy game
which was first announced last september
2020 and since that point has amassed a
whopping 25 million views on its trailer
on the official playstation youtube
channel the trailer just two minutes and
40 seconds in length gave fans their
first glimpse into a new type of harry
potter experience an immersive open
world action role playing game where you
have full control of the type of wizard
you want to be and the type of things
that you want to do
furthermore the trailer gave us a
glimpse of hogwarts in a different time
period a hundred plus years before harry
ever sets foot through its stores set in
the 1800s hogwarts legacy shows us the
wizarding world in an entirely new light
with unfamiliar wizards witches
architecture magic creatures and more if
you're anything like me and you love
harry potter then i'm sure you're
excited at the prospect of more
particularly as we haven't had any new
harry potter content for a number of
years
in the game players will experience life
as a student at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry like never
before as they live the unwritten and
embark on a dangerous journey to uncover
a hidden truth of the wizarding world
furthermore players will grow their
characters abilities as they master
powerful spells own combat skills and
select companions to help them face off
against deadly enemies players will also
encounter missions and scenarios that
will pose difficult choices and
determine what they stand for excited
yet well don't get too excited just yet
because you see we're still reasonably
far away from the game's release falling
short on the original release date
projected for some time in 2021 game
developers released a statement in the
middle of this year explaining that the
game release would be pushed back to
sometime in 2022 however with this
update we weren't provided with a future
date so the question remains when does
hogwarts legacy actually come out
well as it happens the november issue of
toy world magazine actually includes an
interview with warner bros consumer
products general manager rachel wackley
in the interview wackley mentions that
warner bros have two major releases a
film and a game
planned for 2022
the film she's talking about is
obviously fantastic piece three the
secrets of dumbledore and later in the
interview she confirms that the game she
references is in fact hogwarts legacy
the second major release of 2022 will be
for a new console game hogwarts legacy
rockley says the reaction to the trailer
for this has been amazing and it looks
set to be a huge success
given the game is likely going to follow
the release of the film we can
reasonably deduce that hogwarts legacy
will come out sometime after april 15th
if i had to put money on it i'd wager
that hogwarts legacy will be released
early in the second half of 2022 while
harry potter fans are still hyped up
from the film are you guys excited for
this game for this film know anything i
don't comment down below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams forget to live
[Music]
you